escalade une discipline qui grimpe en
france entre 2000 et 2022 le nombre de
licenciés a augmenté de 123 % des
chouettes c'est vraiment accessible à
tous et c'est vraiment ludique
l'escaladent d'aujourd'hui ça n'a rien à
voir avec les années 60 à l'époque
c'était destiné aux administrés il ya
bien quelques adeptes amateurs le lieu
pour s'entraîner la forêt de
fontainebleau inutile de prendre des
risques chaque geste a son importance
ils peuvent vous faire vaincre comme
provoqué une chute à partir des années
70 l'escalette se popularise le grand
public découvre la discipline notamment
grâce à deux grimpeurs pionnier de
l'escaladé libre le premier c'est lui
jean-claude royer
1975 le voici en train d'escalader la
tour montparnasse et techniques
technique de ce qu'est la vie parce
qu'il ya un moyen de progresser avec les
poutrelles verticale en opposition et
grâce aux joints de dilatation on peut
s'assurer
chute éventuelle autre casque ou patrick
edlinger une figure médiatique
véritable star de l' escalade son surnom
le fou grimpant c'est une aventure comme
disait marie là où sa venue c'est devenu
de la routine escalade
qui passe tout mon temps et je retire
une action de satisfaction dans les
années 80 la pratique sportive se
développe un peu plus
première compétition officielle création
de la fédération française d'escaladé et
à grenoble la discipline à son propre
salon c'était en 1987 l' escalade passe
dans la pédagogie beaucoup d'écoles s'y
intéressent et ça va faire naître
cela pourrait appeler des vocations
je pense
dans les cinq ans à venir il y aura
encore un gros gros développement pascal
le grand public peut aussi s'exercer
dans les salles d'escaladé les premières
ouvrent leurs portes dans les années 90
il ya tout type de public ça va des
enfants
qui signe ici les enfants de 4 ans qui
commence à grimper jusqu'à des gens des
meilleurs mondiaux qui viennent
s'entraîner donc la difficulté va ça va
du coup simple au plus compliqué et
c'est pas fini face à cet engouement
l'escaladé même entrée aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo en 2020
plus haut plus vite plus fort enfin la
devise olympique que s'applique à l'
escalade et la polie de l' escalade
n'est pas près de s'arrêter en france à
aubervilliers la plus grande salle
d'escaladé indoor au monde vient
d'ouvrir ses portes au total 7000 m² et
200 parcours jusqu'à 10 mètres de haut
[Musique]